[Musica]
[Applauso]
bene mi presento a voi sono uno
scenografo
anzi sono una scena da foto digitale
è un compito quello di rappresentare la
musa dell'arte
la cosa mi sembra esattamente una cosa
molto distante da quello che sono
realmente e sono neanche in un forte
imbarazzo sinceramente lo trovo anche
una forma di incoscienza presentarsi
come la musa dell'arte però posso
raccontare qualcosa
beh posso raccontare che
sono nato in una famiglia dove l'arte
era la normalità la quotidianità dove
profumo dei colori erano esattamente il
profumo della casa e quindi
ci si svegliava la mattina e sul tavolo
della cucina si
si palesava l'opera ti papà tiziano all
opera della mot mandriana pronti per la
critica ovviamente familiare
è anche vero che
passavo le domeniche
in galleria dai miei genitori
dove assistevo a discussioni o ad
artisti che presentavano le loro opera o
semplicemente e simpatizzanti
ovviamente non comprendevo che cosa che
cosa stavo lippi dentro e che cosa sto
facendo era semplicemente la normalità
delle cose
ricordo anche che di tutta la famiglia
era probabilmente il meno dotato dal
punto di vista artistico dal punto di
vista pittorico
tanto che
alle scuole medie la mia insegnante di
educazione tecnica mi aveva sconsigliato
di fare qualsiasi mestiere o attività o
percorso formativo dove il disegno ci
fosse come materia di studio
ovviamente per me è stata una cosa
migliore dato che sono una persona molto
molto orgogliosa e stata probabilmente
anche uno stimolo e quindi la ringrazio
nel 1989 avevo 20 anni sono stato
cacciato dall accademia di belle arti
e ho iniziato la prima esperienza in
teatro dove ho conosciuto l'amore per
questo mestiere
a trent'anni
dopo dieci anni
mi sono mi hanno offerto
la direzione degli allestimenti di un
ente lirico
oggi
beh oggi
sono
insieme a stefano il mio socio
o un'azienda che si chiama fortuna
per me
la scenografia
è semplicemente una parola lavoro
mestiere
l'arte della scenografia è un'arte
antica
la parola scenografia deriva da un
termine
antico schiene
interviene greco a cui è stato opposto
grafia perché nel tempo
ha preso anche la la connotazione di
rappresentare in qualche maniera il
luogo in cui si svolge l'azione
drammatica
io ho vissuto un
grande cambiamento in questo grande
cambiamento
ovviamente ho modificato la mia
percezione di scenografia quindi oggi
posso dire che la scenografia per me è
in una versione nuova una versione 2.0
sono passato al all'utilizzo degli
strumenti digitali
non perché volessi qualche maniera a
trovare artisticamente uno stile o
volesse in qualche maniera utilizzare
questo strumento per esprimermi ma l'ho
utilizzato esclusivamente
come strumento professionale per far
crescere la mia professionalità
e proprio questa necessità che mi ha
portato a studiare ea progettare le
geografie in digitale
ovviamente
i tempi che ho vissuto mi hanno anche in
qualche maniera spinto a fare questa
scelta perché tempi di produzione sempre
più brevi
competenze artistiche che sparivano
problemi di trasporto
problemi di gestione di budget
tutto questo perché in qualche maniera
viviamo la necessità di ottimizzare
ovviamente queste questa scelta è stata
una scelta che inizialmente è stata
legata al
principalmente al
allo svolgimento e al e all'analisi
della progettata nella fase progettuale
poi oggi invece sta diventando il modo
per costruire i contenuti e per metterne
in onda e quindi un modo nuovo di fare
scenografia
oltre a questo il mondo digitale c'è più
permette di avere una visione
completa di tutto il flusso
queste è stata una grandissima mi
assicura una rivoluzione
facciamo anche un esempio di come non
solo io ovviamente
ho compreso il valore del digitale oggi
se vediamo gli spettacoli che vengono
proposti addirittura la scala di milano
presenta la prima del macbeth
sostituendo il fondale tradizionale
tornari tradizionalmente dipinti con
formale digitale
cioè con un ledwall con uno schermo
questo perché perché vuole creare un
qualcosa che legata al mondo del
dinamismo della velocità del cambiamento
la necessità di raccontare
qualcosa in maniera differente al di là
della valenza e delle scelte stilistiche
di cui non voglio non voglio entrare
questa in questa discussione né tanto
meno in questa non è il luogo per
ovviamente parlare di questo ma si
capisce che c'è la ricerca di fare
qualcosa di diverso
la televisione
fa questo quotidianamente perché la
televisione alla necessità di presentare
velocemente i contenuti e quindi ha
bisogno di mutare lo spazio con una
velocità che diversamente la staticità
di una scenografia tradizionale non
permette
il cinema sta in questo momento
sperimentando e producendo utilizzando
tecniche di virtual set cioè di luoghi
virtuali
totalmente costruiti in computer grafica
dove in qualche maniera la telecamera
viene illusa e quindi questo caso noi
spettatori ognuno illusi
nella visione e quindi pensiamo che
l'oggetto ci sia ma in realtà non c'è è
una tecnica poi tra l'altro tra
virgolette un po vecchia perché lo
faceva hollywood anni 40 50 però oggi ha
una nuova accezione che è quella proprio
della tecnologia è una tecnologia
esasperata
ma come può avvenire il passaggio tra il
pennello
tradizionale al pennello digitale
probabilmente non avevano neanche più
bisogno di rispondere
perché è un passaggio che già avvenuto è
già sotto i nostri occhi non c'è più la
necessità di capire perché
ma perché perché il quotidiano ci ha
fatto capire che questa è la strada
una cosa su cui mi sono
soffermato e cercare di capire come mio
mestiere possa essere proiettato in
funzione non solo di quella che la mia
esperienza nel mondo dello spettacolo se
vogliamo ma in quello che può essere
utile in ambiante ambiti e come si potrà
sviluppare
rispetto ai tempi che viviamo
ho cercato una parola e questa parola è
esperienza
è una parola che in qualche maniera
mi ha fatto ragionare su alcuni aspetti
è un'esperienza reale
l'esperienza del teatro è un'esperienza
reale
il cinema è un'esperienza reale
ma anche un museo
è un'esperienza
ma anche l'acquisto all'interno di un
negozio può essere un'esperienza
è un'esperienza anche una nave da
crociera
esiste anche un'esperienza però virtuale
dove
possiamo sviluppare e possiamo concepire
nuove forme di espressione
attenzione però
per fare tutto questo
dobbiamo
concepire
in una maniera diversa
non possiamo essere semplicemente degli
user degli utilizzatori di tecnologia
dei consumatori di tecnologia
non è sufficiente conoscere dei software
non è sufficiente utilizzare un computer
dobbiamo diventare degli artigiani
digitali cioè dobbiamo diventare
dei professionisti
che costruiscono gli strumenti ma che
costruiscono principalmente la materia
digitale
e quando parlo di materia digitale parlo
di un qualcosa che nasce interamente
concepita all'interno del mondo digitale
e non semplicemente una sostituzione di
un manufatto in questo caso scenografico
tradizionale con uno tecnologico
e dove la creatività
è una dei componenti dell'esperienza
abbiamo ovviamente
questo concetto lo possiamo applicare
molto in maniera molto efficace nel
mondo virtuale
dove possiamo in qualche maniera
prototipare l'esperienza reale ma
possiamo anche fruire dell'esperienza
la cosa incredibile che alla fine stiamo
facendo un illusione sensoriale
dove
il centro è la nostra percezione
che poi alla fine è quello che tanto ci
meraviglia tanto ci emoziona ci stupisce
oserei dire un salto nel passato di 300
anni
servono le infrastrutture
servono i luoghi con le infrastrutture
serve
studiare
serve fare esperienza
serve mettere in discussione sicuramente
le nostre certezze e le nostre
competenze
probabilmente questo per costruire
un pubblico diverso o forse un pubblico
e in un diverso luogo
un altro concetto e altri due concetti
che mi su cui vorrei in qualche maniera
a parlare è l'immersività e
l'interattività
ma cosa vuol dire immersività
è semplicemente un luogo siamo
circondati da un qualcosa che ci avvolge
quindi immersività è il salone lumière
di parigi dove possiamo vedere le opere
in una maniera differente
si potrebbe essere questo come potrebbe
anche essere un planetario ma
un luogo immersivo
ma perché vogliamo emerger c
perché vogliamo un luogo diverso
da quello reale
forse perché vogliamo un luogo dove
tutto è possibile
forse perché vogliamo sentire
sulla pelle
un'emozione
forse perché vogliamo sublimare le
nostre sensazioni
e percepirle con un forte pathos
nei luoghi fisici
le sensazioni
diventano condivise
nei luoghi virtuali
le sensazioni sono straordinariamente ed
emotivamente
forti ma private
abbiamo bisogno anche però di
partecipare interattivamente alle cose
perché vogliamo fare un'esperienza
perché vogliamo essere al centro
dell'esperienza
potrei dirvi che l'interattività può
servire a tante cose può servire nel
mondo dello spettacolo a visualizzare la
musica a tradurre la musica in immagine
audio re active si chiama questa
questo questo modo
posso anche pensare che in qualche
maniera tecnicamente
risolvere delle problematiche tecniche
di spettacolo con delle interattività
oggi però la cosa interessante è che un
settore settore dell'edutainment
educare intrattenendo sta andando in
questa direzione sta cercando di
sviluppare questo tipo di attività
perché perché
diventando il soggetto principale del
racconto diventiamo in qualche maniera
impariamo e abbiamo capito che possiamo
imparare facendo un'esperienza anche
un'esperienza virtuale un'esperienza
diretta
divertendoci questo è un settore in
forte espansione
ma di tutto questo
che ho detto tutto questo a che fare con
l'arte beh ho fatto porto questa
conclusione se la scenografia è
concepita come
una branca dell'arte
e non può essere contenuta
non si può
pensare che l'arte non abbia la
necessità di trovare strumenti nuovi
e una maniera innovativa per potersi
presentare non è possibile
contenerla
e se questo è un processo di
trasformazione che sta coinvolgendo
tutte le forme d'arte
non posso dire che sono l'espressione
dell'oggi ma sono anche la visione di un
futuro
grazie
[Applauso]